le ruban est coupé après 17 mois de
fermeture
la fête peut désormais reprendre dans
cette boîte de nuit londonienne fini les
masques les règles de distanciation
sociale et les limites à la
fréquentation des théâtres ou des grands
événements c'est une occasion très
joyeuse et j'aime danser et tout mon
cercle d'amis aime danser et nous
n'avons pas pu le faire depuis un an et
demi environ donc nous sommes vraiment
excités à ce sujet ce masque ne le
montre pas mais il ya un petit sourire
en dessous une levée des dernières
restrictions sanitaires jugé nécessaire
par le premier ministre britannique
10 c'est donc le bon moment mais nous
devons agir avec prudence
nous devons nous rendre compte que ce
virus est toujours là que le nombre de
cas augmente nous pouvons constater
l'extrême contagiosité du variant delta
mais nous avons cette immense
consolation et cette satisfaction de
savoir qu il ne fait aucun doute que le
programme de vaccination a gravement
affaibli le lien entre maladie
hospitalisations et décès et c'est ce
qui est primordial
ironie du sort à la veille de ce freedom
day pour jour de la liberté
boris johnson déclaré qu'à contacter le
18 juillet devra s'isoler quand il ne
travaille pas de quoi laisser les
britanniques perplexe pour les
scientifiques
cette levée des dernières contraintes
sanitaires est qualifiée de dangereuse
et inadapté vu la situation du pays
n'était pas le bon moment pour lever
complètement toutes les restrictions
alors que les niveaux d'infections et
d'hospitalisation augmente et même si la
vaccination est considérablement
affaibli le lien entre les infections
les hospitalisations et les décès nous
sommes toujours dans une position très
difficile ici en angleterre et je pense
que ce n'est pas le bon moment pour
lever toutes les restrictions end dans
un communiqué mille deux cents
scientifiques internationaux critiquent
la décision de boris johnson
il assure que son plan pourrait
entraîner un à deux millions de
contaminations ces prochaines semaines
et potentiellement plus de cent mille
nouveaux cas de co vide par jour au
cours de l'été
d
six nations qui risque d'aggraver un
bilan déjà dramatique avec plus de 128
mille morts
le royaume uni reste le pays le plus
meurtrier en europe par le coronavirus